Let's go to the phones at (617) 830-4750 a
lot of people eager to get on today. Let's
start with our caller from the eight oh six
area code. Who's calling today from eight
oh six
hello. How's it going?
Good. Who's this?
My name's uh, Lamar.
Hey Lamont. What's up?
Hey, I just had a quick question. It's a little
open ended. As you know, there's a lot of
democratic candidates in particular mind,
which is Bernie Sanders talking about increasing
minimum wage. Now I know that he and many
others have been trying to do this since the
nineties et cetera. I wanted to know even
after he leaves, what we have is a major problem
systemic, in my opinion, which is the cost
of inflation or the rate of inflation continues
to change. I know that there's different things
like the fair Labor Standard Act or different
acts that were made. I just wanted to hear
your thoughts on do you believe that whoever
the candidate is, whether it Bernie or Elizabeth
or whoever should set up an agency or give
more power to an agency that's independent
of Congress to be able to naturally adjust
the minimum wage without having to go through
Congress with a great luck, a bunch of foolishness,
et cetera?
Yeah, I mean, so the answer is yes, the minimum
wage should be indexed to inflation, inflation
merely to keep up with inflation. The, the
more complicated element of it is that cost
of living is arguably, uh, more difficult
to pin down than national inflation. And that
because the minimum wage is very regionalized,
what counts as a living wage in some parts
of the country is not in other parts of the
country. So there are some studies which suggest
that you should actually tie the minimum wage
to cost of living, which of course is very,
very different in different parts of the country
and even within states. And that's where we
should be looking in po both politically and
logistically. That's much more difficult.
Now let me say one other thing, Lamont. We
actually have it pretty good in the United
States as far as inflation in my birth country
of Argentina, the inflation is, I mean it's,
it's been cartoonish for 15 years. It's crazy
what's going on there. And in the u s fortunately,
yes, there's a political obstacle to overcome
in terms of getting the minimum wage index
to inflation, but at least our inflation is
very, very low compared to what's going on
in countries like Argentina. And it's not
nearly as big of a problem as it could be.
Thank you. I really appreciate your thoughts.
Love you. So keep up the great work.
All right. Thank you very much. I appreciate
hearing from you Lamont.